INSTRUCTOR: Good morning.
Good morning.
So, anybody check The New
York Times yesterday?
What did you see?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: People,
what people?
AUDIENCE: I can't remember
their names.
[INAUDIBLE]
INSTRUCTOR: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I can't remember their names.
INSTRUCTOR: Yeah, the Crick
and Watson people.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
INSTRUCTOR: Exactly.
So, perfect timing, The New York
Times had an article in
yesterday's paper.
Francis Crick's correspondence
with Maurice Wilkins during
the critical year when Crick and
Watson went down and saw
the X-ray crystallography.
By the way, I made a mistake.
I said that Rosalind Franklin
showed it to Crick and Watson.
Actually it was Maurice Wilkins
who showed it to Crick
and Watson when Rosalind
Franklin was away.
Which, was itself a slightly
complicated thing to be doing
because it was really Rosalind
Franklin's work.
But in any case, there was
correspondence, some heated
correspondence that went
back between Crick
and Wilkins and others.
And it was believed that the
correspondence had been lost,
had been thrown out.
But in fact, it turns out that
in the papers of Sydney
Brenner, another great person
of that period, Crick's
correspondence had got misfiled
in Sydney's files.
Sydney had donated his files
to the Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory on Long Island.
And they went through the files
in the past several
months and found them.
So we actually now have, as The
New York Times reported
yesterday, the letters with
Crick and Watson and Maurice
Wilkins about just that period
I was telling you about.
It doesn't radically change
any of the story.
But it really shows
you the attitude.
And if you read the New York
Times article, you'll find all
sorts of juicy quotes about the
attitude back and forth
there, including the first model
Crick and Watson made
where they totally screwed up
because they had misunderstood
some number.
Anyway, it's interesting
stuff.
And the reason I bring up this
history is because science is
done by real people.
It's a business of passion.
It's a business of trying
to-- you know --
science is wonderful.
It's objective in
a certain sense.
And it's also about
convincing others.
You know, a scientific result
doesn't mean anything unless
you can convince
the community.
So it's an inherently human
activity to bring people's
attention to things,
make things clear.
Anyway, that was kind of cool.
I invite you all to go look
at The Times article.
You don't realize how much work
we have to go to in 7.01
to arrange these things to come
out just at the right
time during our curriculum.
But we pay off The New York
Times and they do our bidding.
So last time we were
talking about--
I want to briefly go back to
the Semiconservative Model,
which I ended with last time,
of DNA replication, the work
of Matt Meselson and Frank
Stahl, these graduate students
at Caltech.
So you remember, our DNA double
helix immediately
suggests the secret of life,
the way that you copy
information to daughter cells.
Each strand is a sufficient
template for the other strand.
If you just unzipped them, each
would be able to serve as
a template for replication
for the other strand.
Beautiful.
It's called Semiconservative
because you've conserved.
You used one strand.
And you've made a new
strand on the other.
It seems obvious, but
we can't take things
for obvious in science.
Because the alternative model,
alternative, which we know
today is of course wrong, is
that somehow the cell comes
along, feels this double helix
as a template, and somehow
builds two new strands
that are the same
as that double helix.
They build a new double helix
with both strands being new.
That's nuts--
why would you do it?
It's so obvious you could
use one strand as the
template for the other.
But this is what Meselson and
Stahl had to rule out.
They had to rule out that that
double helix stayed intact,
and maybe the cell sent some
enzymes around to feel its
shape and somehow construct
another double helix like it.
That would be a non-conservative
model.
You weren't using
any old strands.
The two old strands
stayed together.
And you made two new strands.
That's what they were trying to
distinguish between, this
semiconservative model or not.
So I just remind you that their
really cool, cool idea--
see, they couldn't use a
radioactive tracer that was
different on the new strand
than the old strand in the
conventional sense.
Because, of course, they're made
out of the same atoms.
But what they did do, as we
talked about last time, was
they take the DNA.
They grow it up in
heavy nitrogen.
They then shift the bacteria
to light nitrogen.
And, if in fact the
Semiconservative Model is
right, then the new DNA after
one generation of growth will
have a lighter density.
Very simple, except that they
had to go invent a way to
measure density.
They had to invent this
centrifugation process where
they spin really, really,
really, really hard.
And the salt gets a little
denser here, and a little less
dense here, and a little
less dense here.
And it's not a very
huge difference.
But if you know the density of
DNA, and you arrange your salt
concentration at just the right
density, you can spin it
really hard so that there's
some gradient in
density in the salt.
And the heavier stuff
will band here.
The lighter stuff from
one generation of
growth will band there.
And normal DNA would
band there.
And that's a pretty
convincing proof.
After no generations
it's all in 15-15.
After one generation it's
all intermediate.
After two generations some
of it is now 14-14.
Some of it is 14-15.
And onward like that.
Obvious, and it's a gorgeous
experiment, just a gorgeous
experiment.
And this idea of density
centrifugation, which they
invented for this purpose, has
been used for many other
purposes since.